my favorite show is shark tank oh my god
I love the way that they reject people
on Shark Tank right so classy don't you
wish you could use that same tactic just
got a boring conversations with people
in your life and your in your office
like oh I got to stop you right there
Mike I don't see anything proprietary
about your conversation about the
weather
it lacks creativity and I don't see
myself getting excited in the future so
for those reasons I'm out but that feels
like when you plug your USB cord in
right side up first try I have seen
every episode of shark tank because I
have a prescription for adderall holy
adderall is dangerous essentially
what happened with adderall is the
government was like okay cocaine is bad
and then we were like but what if we
made it blue like you got us there
I guess give it to every child that even
breaks eye contact
I got prescribed adderall because I'm
severely dyslexic and I got prescribed
adderall so I could really you know
focus on how I can't read
it's very frustrating being dyslexic cuz
no one takes it seriously because
everyone uses it as an excuse for bad
grammar all right like people will
misspell a word in a text and then we'll
follow that up its our e about that I'm
so dyslexic it's like no you're thinking
of stupid don't text me that with your
green text bubble that's a red flag
about someone right they text you green
text bubble pop saying lenta android did
you know Megan was poor texting someone
a green text bubbles like text in the
link to your GoFundMe page do you notice
all the people that are not laughing at
that they don't know that we know every
text is green huh ah not for us one
percenters it's okay I grew up poor
that's why actually I didn't find out I
was dyslexic to way later in life it
wasn't tested for growing up because
people just presume that poor people are
stupid
in fact people presume that poor people
are stupid so often that when a poor
person is not stupid oh then it's like a
whole goddamn movie
it's like a whole Good Will Hunting
where the entire premise is just could
you imagine a world with this piece of
that mops our floors understood man
Oh give it every Oscar by far though the
most frustrating thing about being an
adult that don't not know read good is
that whenever I need to learn something
now I have to sit through an entire
YouTube tutorial I have to sit through
an entire 19 minute to 36 day long
rambling stream of conscious mistake
filled from a 14-year old video do the
people that record tutorial videos do
they know that they're allowed to do a
second take hi guys it's reigai here
back with another slyguy tutorial first
things first
okay sorry about that alright let's go
ahead and open up Google Oh so Google is
asking me to update not a problem let's
just go ahead and download that update
and then wait for it in real time
and that's the good ones the other 90%
of these tutorial videos for some reason
are all recorded by my East East Eastern
European ancestors where it's like not
only can you not place our accent but
the accent sounds like someone is still
building a mouth it's like who died but
a dub over for sure it's not no problem
is I evanthia i've above it just below
so what i tried to draw the subtitles in
the wing-dings font came on your
tutorial now clicking on another video
and learning that check is the official
language which is a Slavic based on that
is mutually intelligible to the saw
backs across the border oh and what's
this if it's a Czechoslovakia Slovakia
and the Czech Republic because they
always be the same country as early as
1993 before the Soviet Union intervened
which leads me to another video with the
locals will say it's actually the
distinguishable architecture which
incorporates both classical Baroque and
gothic elements because innate
colonnades embellishing the for yeas and
corridors and this is all becoming
incredibly boring and I don't see myself
getting excited in the future so for
those reasons I'm out
[Applause]